[Music]
good morning Hank it's good morning Hank
it's Monday and when I say good morning
I mean oh it's five o'clock in the
morning and I'm miserable as you can
tell from the speckled gray background
I'm in the Indianapolis Airport and Hank
as you no doubt recall the one thing
that I really like about the
Indianapolis Airport is its pretzels but
I got here too early and the pretzel
stand isn't even open yet I'm a cranky
Frankie I hate you five o'clock Monday
morning I hate you
but Hank as unhappy as I am I'm not
nearly as unhappy as the yetis going to
be when she wakes up and learns that
this morning at four o'clock when I was
packing to get ready to come here I
accidentally put her car key in my
pocket Hank why did I do that seriously
honestly Hank I hope you won't take this
personally but I don't want to talk to
you right now
okay because you can tell by the
slightly different speckled gray
background behind me I am no longer in
Indianapolis I am now in Atlanta I
seriously cannot believe that I left
Sarah and Indianapolis without a car
that's a terrible thing to do to a
person Hank it's a terrible thing to do
to a person you love Wow Hank that
footage was shot by a guy who was
incredibly depressed now I'm in a much
better mood Hank I flew to Boston today
to hang out with MT Anderson and work
with him on this little project that
we're doing it was really fun and it
totally made my day although as days go
this was an easy one to make
plus then he wanted to give you in the
nerdfighters a personal guide to the art
in his living room
Hank Johns asked me to say something all
I really have to say is about my artwork
hanging on the wall of my apartment here
here we have the young lovers here we
have some young body parasites and there
we have the central nervous system the
idea of being of course that you should
remember as you sit there nestled with
your loved ones that all of these things
are still living on you and love may be
found within you but it is also found
very much in your mouth and your
eyebrows there's loving going on all
over your body
it's a beautiful thing hanging and then
I got to my hotel and I have to say Hank
after a really long day this hotel makes
me incredibly happy it's a hotel on the
campus of MIT and the elevators are all
like this is the future and the
comforters have mathematical equations
on them and the chairs appear to be made
out of atoms of course I suppose that
one could argue that all chairs are made
out of atoms Hank I hope that they might
be giants was they might be awesome and
I'll see you tomorrow